those who are going to win are going to
outwork out learn Outlast but also out
strategize the competition most YouTube
creators have not studied the landscape
of their industry and have not
thoughtfully analyzed what are the other
options that are like my channel
different is better than better what are
your advantages how can you use your
small YouTube channel to create a big
Advantage when you make the ideal
product that fits that person perfectly
and that's maybe a little bit too Niche
all the other competitors in the space
would never narrow down that far but
that's your opportunity
so how can small YouTube creators win
against big competitors in this video
I'm going to be breaking down four
strategies that almost nobody is talking
about when it comes to getting an edge
on YouTube we're also going to be
talking about must know YouTube
marketing principles that we can learn
from military generals and I actually
discovered some YouTube secrets in a
book called marketing Warfare and I read
it so you don't have to and inside are
tips on how you can go from Underdog to
Champion and I've seen this proven in
the YouTube landscape but I've got to
warn you this episode is a little bit
more advanced and we're gonna get geeky
but if you're ready for it buckle your
seat belt and let's dive in in the book
marketing Warfare and its companion book
positioning two Classics and marketing
they reveal really the keys to standing
out in business and in marketing and
what I realized when reading the books
though was that these were like manuals
for winning on YouTube as well but it
also revealed why a lot of small
channels stay small because ultimately
they're approaching YouTube with the
wrong approach so let's talk about the
four different styles of marketing
Warfare and we'll talk about how they
apply to YouTube and then I have three
specific tips so that you can start
winning as a small YouTube channel hit
your income goals hit your growth goals
But ultimately probably approach YouTube
different than you have been in the past
so here's what the marketing Warfare
book teaches four types of warfare
there's defensive Warfare offensive
Warfare flanking Warfare and guerrilla
warfare question is which one should you
be using and honestly
everybody listening to this should only
be using one type and the reason a lot
of people fail is because they're doing
defensive Warfare when they should be
doing guerrilla warfare or so on and so
forth I'll explain what these mean so
defensive Warfare
is only for the market leader
question for you who's the market leader
in your Niche who is the biggest Channel
who's the dominant Voice or that very
few biggest largest channels in your
Niche offensive Warfare should only be
used for number two and number three
companies Who's the who are the second
tier channels in your channel topic
flanking Warfare should be used for
smaller companies I would say this would
be used for smaller established YouTube
channels and then guerrilla warfare
should only be used for local or
Regional companies in this case I would
say brand new YouTube channels and
probably you if you clicked on this
podcast episode because you're trying to
break through an uphill battle where it
feels fears like feels like the
competition is too Fierce here's what's
fascinating as I'm reading this book I
eventually discover that only about one
or two YouTube channels
should be doing defensive Warfare they
know they're number one and they're
defending their position in the book
this would say you're Coca-Cola you know
you're the number one Cola Company and
your job is to just defend your position
of being number one offensive Warfare
which you might think I'm on offense I'm
trying to grow I'm on my hustle
offensive Warfare is only for number two
and number three companies in a field
that means Pepsi and perhaps RC Cola
from back in the day or fill in the
blank another Cola brand they're the
only ones that should be actually doing
offense
flanking Warfare so that's maybe let's
call it you know three of the biggest
YouTube channels you have and you may
have something like let's say Mr Beast
is in entertainment he's like the market
leader let's say T-Series like the
market leader if they just keep doing
what they're doing and they keep
doubling down the momentum they have
they just kind of are defending their
position now follow me because there's a
lot of insights here where obviously I'm
pulling principles from this book into
the YouTube industry but the big key is
if you're acting like Mr Beast by the
way you can't even you you can't spend a
million or two million or three million
dollars per video and critics would say
oh yeah but I could just say Logan Paul
16 000 times or something like he did on
his come up well sure it's a good point
because that was really weird and really
different at the time but you got to be
really thoughtful about where do you sit
on this spectrum and are you approaching
YouTube wrong so defensive Warfare
number one that's like one or two
channels probably offensive Warfare is
probably like less than 10. for blanking
Warfare is probably like less than a
hundred and then guerrilla warfare is
everybody else here's the good news
there is hope for you but as a small
YouTube Creator guerrilla warfare is
going to be the main strategy that
you're going to want to focus on let's
go a little bit deeper before we get
into our three tips so defensive Warfare
is only the market leader when you're
number one your goal is just to defend
the position and the way that you
innovate or your
strategy when you're in defensive
Warfare is actually to attack Yourself
by the way as weird as that sounds we're
going through these books as a
leadership team right now at think media
and all four of these would apply to you
if you're if you're Die Hard in our
community and I told you this is going
to get a little bit geeky if you know
you're a little bit more of in a
dominant position you're you can never
be complacent your goal is to attack
Yourself by improving your own products
reinvent Yourself by improving your own
videos but you know you're number one or
you know you're in a dominant position
but the number one leader and I'm not
suggesting remember we're not like but
leaders must attack themselves Mr Beast
has got to be thinking man how do I
level up my last video how do I out do
what anybody who's now copying me which
many people are how do I attack myself
and improve my own products
um and all moves by competitors must be
matched all right offensive Warfare the
strengths of number one in the market
this is interesting you identify who is
the dominant player in my industry or my
Niche what are their strengths and then
here's is the key you find their
weaknesses and then you attack at that
single point
interesting you find the area because
everybody has weaknesses and you attack
at that single point and you combine the
attack to that single point
hint both of these strategies defense or
offense
probably don't apply to most of us but
this would be the idea that you could
get some of the market share
of one of the dominant players because
you identify their weakness and you
exploit their weakness by the way this
episode's up for the fate of heart
you're like this sounds a little
aggressive well yeah the book's called
marketing Warfare so I mean we're you
know we're speaking in Warfare terms
number three this is it fascinating
flanking Warfare you're going to
introduce a new product to an
uncontested area
now this might be a this must be a
surprise attack and you never advertise
it in the beginning and you pour
everything you can into the flanking
move to be successful you find an
uncontested area of the marketplace
and you just go super deep and you
introduce something new to that area of
the marketplace so how do you bring
something new to Tech and camera tips or
how do you bring something new to real
estate investing and uh Financial advice
how do you bring something new to DIY
how do you bring something fresh that
goes what does flanking mean it means
you're just going around huge key the
mistake people make is they look at who
the number one person is and you think
that's your competition you think about
attacking them you do not attack the
market leader You're Gonna Lose You
don't attack the number two and number
three You're Gonna Lose You go around
and then number four where most of us
will land is guerrilla warfare and check
this out you're gonna find a market
segment small enough to defend and you
never act like the market leader and
you're actually ready to move elsewhere
at a moment's notice so guerrilla
warfare itself is very disruptive
against you think about a massive
military force well what does guerrilla
warfare do it takes it to the tree it
takes it to the forest it takes the two
surprise attack it takes the two we're
Nimble we have a small enough Force
where we could be fast we can be nimble
that becomes your opportunity and my
goal in this episode is to get you to
think outside of the box it's kind of a
part of a strategy series we're doing
here on the think media podcast channel
to give you hope and help you think
outside of the box that the reason a lot
of people stay stuck on YouTube is
they're acting like the number one but
they can't compete because you don't got
the budget you don't got the team
they're acting like the market leader
but they're already the market leader
and if you're just trying to be them
you're just an echo of them
and you're even trying to attack the
market leader you're you're getting and
I don't mean you're actually calling
them out or anything although you may be
but it's it's not working and so
ultimately your goal is to find a market
segment small enough to defend you find
some Niche angle and again these books
were written for businesses but I know
we have a very business-minded community
and so when you start also thinking
bigger than your YouTube channel what is
my angle what is my product what is my
service who am I trying to help what am
I going to sell the guerrilla warfare
opportunity for the small YouTube
channel becomes okay I found a very
niche market and if you haven't listened
to our episode about the 13 ways to
stand out on YouTube like I maybe found
out that man my YouTube channel is video
marketing tips for real estate agents
and maybe in America that now you're
starting to have a very specific makes
me kind of think and I'm obviously being
self-referential here because I'm very
well of my industry
so uh there's a good book it's called
YouTube for real estate agents I
actually don't know if it's good I
haven't read it but I mean the reason
it's great is
I wrote a book called YouTube secrets
with my friend Benji that book is
probably the number one YouTube strategy
book in the world over a hundred
thousand copies sold
Daryl Eves wrote a book called YouTube
formula that book is is probably number
two now by the way we're not talking
about which one's better who knows maybe
they're both terrible but we're talking
about dominance rankings on Amazon I'm
out of reviews on Amazon so follow me so
you can follow the illustration now
there's others that
are also writing YouTube books
perhaps the trouble is though is like
when it comes to ranking volume reviews
momentum you've got like the number one
the number two the number three whoever
that is whatever then you've got YouTube
for real estate agents
an absolute brilliant title
in a competitive place like do you try
to write a book to outrank and beat
YouTube formula by derral Eves or
YouTube Secrets by Sean Cannell maybe
but could be a losing proposition you
think about ranking on Amazon what do
you do instead completely flank us and
write YouTube for real estate agents or
guerrilla warfare you know do something
that's even more Niche or more specific
in that case a market segment small
enough to defend again you write a book
about a niche within a niche within a
niche see what I'm where I'm going with
this is ultimately your goal is to Niche
down and find a market segment small
enough to defend if you're still hanging
me with me in this episode I've got
three tips for you I'm sharing with you
my takeaways and insights from marketing
Warfare which I know every business
owner is loving this conversation this
again is thinking about your product how
it's marketed I definitely recommend the
book and the other book positioning
that's the more famous One it's on its
20th anniversary edition and uh
subscribe to the podcast because I I'm
gonna have an episode breaking down some
tips from that one as well but before we
get into these tips today's episode is
brought to you by findyourtopic.com and
if all of this is all a little bit
confusing and in general you're still
like Sean I don't really know though how
to position my Channel or I'd love to
just make all of this stuff simple and
figure out what would be the best
channel topic for me where as a small
Creator a new Creator I could figure out
how to stand out this class is totally
free and it'll help you go from
confusion to Clarity if you go to
findyourtopic.com
you could register and it'll also help
you find the best path to personally
earn money
um and figure out your profitable Niche
here's the cool thing right you take a
channel like Mr Beast and he was offered
a billion dollars and he turned it down
he's got hundreds of staff I think now
and contractors he's also got multiple
businesses so again that's not even your
competition
right it's a whole it's a whole
different
sector you take a hundred channels that
are at the next level down that's not
your competition either your goal is
guerrilla warfare to find your Niche to
also realize that we are living in an
era
where
a small YouTube creator with 5 10 15 000
subscribers with the right business
model in the right positioning and the
right marketing Warfare strategy can
earn thirty eight thousand fifty two
thousand sixty five thousand dollars a
year and do this thing full time
whatever your targets are
because again you found a market segment
small enough to defend so if you're
interested in going a little bit deeper
findyourtopic.com but let's get into
these tips that are way outside of the
box compared to what most people are
telling you and some insights that came
out of this book marketing Warfare by
alries and Jack trout number one become
competitor oriented all right this is
crazy because what 99 of people will
tell you and in YouTube typically you
say become obsessed with the viewer
which I agree with by the way
call out to some of our comments every
once in a while we get a comment on the
YouTube version of this and someone will
be like you said reels are going viral
but they're not going viral listen
one of the things we have to embrace As
Leaders is tensions so some things are
not everybody wants everything to be
black and white when a lot of times
there's gray in the middle but but
things are their tensions to be managed
they're not a problem to be solved
so sometimes it's like well should I be
you said be customer oriented and the
Creator who understands the viewer best
wins so now if you're saying be be
competitor oriented and the Creator who
understands their competitors best wins
which is it both
tensions
so what's fascinating about this is
a lot of times you've heard me say don't
compare yourself to the competition it's
your race your pace don't worry about
your competitors focus on you
which is all true and is also really
good for your mental health but I told
you this is going to be a little bit
more advanced the real players that are
doing marketing Warfare are aware of the
competition they are thoughtful about
the competition they study the
competition Simon sinek talks defines it
this way he calls them worthy Rivals and
and I'm not trying to be so aggressive
like this episode might be hard for some
people because you're like is it really
does it have to be a fight well business
is war in some regard it's a competition
for attention I can hold intention in
myself knowing that there is enough
opportunity in the world for all of us I
really believe that there's 2.6 billion
monthly active users there's a lot of
opportunity there one of the comment I'm
referring to that someone brought up was
chalene Johnson recently was like we're
kind of going through a social media
recession because there's so many people
posting content and they're just like
but there's also I don't agree with that
there's also a lot of opportunity who's
right everybody not that everybody's
always right but like yeah there is
people's attention is getting worn down
so you have to adapt your strategy but
is there also massive opportunity
because there's Rising consumption yes
friend I want to ask you
if you want to grow and become a true
strategist you got to be able to embrace
tension attention saying okay yeah I
absolutely need to like be obsessed with
the viewer and not worry about the
competition but I also need the maturity
to do a competitive analysis and to be
thoughtful about what other competitors
are there in my space 99 of small
YouTubers have not done very good market
research most YouTube creators have not
studied the landscape of their industry
and have not thoughtfully
analyzed what are the other options
that are like my channel what are the
opportunities what are the differences
and similarities between the top
channels in my industry like these
things will really help you if you'll
Embrace this next level of of thinking
about strategy so number one become
competitor oriented I don't mean get
insecure I don't mean like toxically
compare yourself but I mean actually
understand what's happening with your
competitors one of the most common
pitfalls among strategists is
competitive neglect neglect of studying
your competitors
we are susceptible to a false mental
image too that our competitors are
standing still and we're the only ones
moving so what does that mean it also
means that not only are you trying to
grow right now but so is everybody else
not only are you trying to break through
in your industry but so is everybody
else so if everybody's moving and
there's certain competitors that are
moving this is why you got to get your
butt in gear you got to be out working
out learning out strategizing and
outlasting
the competition with Sean it feels like
an uphill battle remember the
competition isn't the million subscribed
YouTube channel it's someone that's in
the circle it's finding the distinction
at your size and playing by the rules
and strategies and tactics of your size
of channel that you should be applying
successful companies and all insert
successful YouTubers today are
competitor oriented so they are
thoughtful here's the key you still are
trying to satisfy the viewer so the
question you're asking when looking at
the competitors is what are the
strengths of the content that's already
out there what are the weaknesses of the
content that's already out there and
then how can I ultimately create some
competitive advantages by understanding
who's who's playing defense who's number
one who's who should be playing offense
right now the number two number three
and and who's flanking right now and
then who and if I'm doing gorilla
Warfare I've identified the point of
opportunity if all this sounds hard
it's because it is but you know what's
waiting for you on the other side of
finally studying the landscape and then
being there it is there's that moment
that moment of breakthrough is a six
figure a year YouTube channel and a six
figure a year YouTube business it's on
the other side of you studying your
competitors
and figuring out where the opportunity
is this video was brought to you by
stream yard stream yard is our go-to
platform for streaming to YouTube and
Facebook with an incredibly easy to use
interface for built-in branding
transitions text lower thirds and
seamlessly bringing on guests it really
is one of the best options when it comes
to live streaming and what's so cool is
they've implemented a brand new feature
called local recording take control of
your audio and video with local
recordings by separating out your audio
and video from your guests this feature
gives you the control over your content
for later use making it perfect for
podcasts and video creators just go to
streamwoodthink.com to get started now
if you think about a chess master no
moves or ad hoc strategy might make you
a little bit uncomfortable or you might
feel a little stretched of being like
this is a little bit different just tell
me how to get views this is how to get
views if you're playing chess
you know people aren't just like okay I
like the horsey one let me you know put
him out there what does this one do oh
the queen she seems cool like no every
move
is intentional and success comes from
thinking several steps ahead where's the
market going where are the Trends on
YouTube right now where are people
getting fatigued with certain styles of
content is the Mr beastification of
YouTube gonna be a problem and what's
the next move what how could I position
myself now how could I look at the
comments on my competitors channels to
look at what the complaints are and see
that as an opportunity by the way
there's some Ninja strategy for you in
the midst of our marketing Warfare
conversation today guerrilla warfare
is
finding a market segment falling small
enough to defend and finding one that
your competitors can't even do because
they're too busy you go to your channels
channels that are your competitors you
read their comments and you see someone
saying I wish you would make videos like
this listen they probably want to but
maybe where they at are in their season
of life I just can relate to this
because I'm like we literally have
thousands of videos we need to make it
think media and that's no joke and we
can't even
let's do that with the team that we have
we're working towards it we got to pick
our battles everyone's got to pick their
battles but we're also thoughtful we're
focusing our energy on the most
important battles for us right now which
are also bigger battles or they're
related to the size we're at right so
you think about okay there's maybe like
a theme in think media's comments
there's a theme in my competitor's
comments and that's an opportunity to
start a Channel or do a video series to
solve that specific problem and then
boom that Insight happened not because
you were just customer oriented or
rather viewer oriented the Insight
happened because you were competitor
oriented number two become a strategist
realize that small YouTube channels your
small YouTube channel could be your
biggest opportunity realize
your small YouTube channel could be your
biggest opportunity
now a lot of the insights out of this
book came from Carl Von kloswitz who
wrote a book called on war and there's
many quotes each chapter has like a
quote from that book
and here's what he says the greatest
possible number number of troops should
be brought into action at a decisive
point and there is no higher and simpler
law of strategy than keeping one's
forces concentrated
the talent of the strategist is to
identify the decisive point and to
concentrate everything on it removing
forces from secondary fronts and
ignoring lesser objectives while this
episode maybe will bomb because you know
it's a little bit different than we
normally do or maybe if you love it let
me know and give me your feedback
especially on the YouTube version of the
podcast because that's where comments
can be posted
and let me know if you want more of this
stuff or if you're like I don't know
this wasn't your greatest episode but I
actually think that this is the level of
thinking we need to go to to become a
strategist those who are going to win
are going to outwork out learn Outlast
but also out strategize the competition
and your small YouTube channel could be
your biggest opportunity why because
when you do guerrilla warfare
you just pick a slice of the market you
pick a type of a video series you find
something someone else isn't covering
see people are doing this every single
day in our video ranking Academy they've
been frustrated because they posted 50
100 200 250 videos but then they pivoted
a little bit then they found a different
angle then they found a different
decisive point
and here's a key then they put all the
greatest number of troops they have and
remember you don't have a massive staff
massive budget millions of dollars to
make videos so you take all your troops
might be you in the 10 hours a week you
can devote to this your troops is the
the money in your bank account the time
on your calendar and it's a very little
amount of time and energy one of the
mistakes people make is again when you
look at the competition your competition
depending on how far they have a bigger
budget they have more team and you're
out here complaining and being
frustrated like if only I had no no your
greatest strength is your size you're
not trying to go on defense or offense
or flank guerrilla warfare you're like
okay I'm gonna find this decisive point
and I'm going to put the greatest number
of troops against that decisive point
there is no higher or simple simpler law
of strategy than than also keeping one's
forces concentrated okay Sean make it
simple make it plain so I look at your
YouTube channel you got 100 videos about
a bunch of random topics your titles
suck the thumbnails are terrible and I
don't know what your channel is about
it's not concentrated or you've got a
hundred decent videos decent titles
decent thumbnails but you're making
you're talking about topics that all of
the tier one two and three competitors
are talking about and you've deluded to
your top like your topics are all over
the place the goal was to figure out
that angle that Niche that specific
point of attack
and then keep your forces concentrated
more important still
is the talent of the strategist we got
to become a strategist number two is to
identify this point and then to
concentrate everything on it and then
remove forces from secondary fronts and
ignore lesser objectives that could be
making the wrong videos but that also
could just be stop wasting time on stuff
that you don't have energy for what does
that mean you compare yourself to think
media you go well Sean is doing vertical
video on every platform Sean's posting
328 pieces of content a week yeah you
that you should not compete with us on
that if you're just starting there's a
lot of people helping me but I built
here Brick by Brick piece by piece
so if you're imitating what I'm doing
you're diluting your focus so let's do
you see the connection between the
principle of marketing Warfare or the
principle of warfare in general you
figure out the point of attack and you
concentrate everything on it focus and
then you remove forces from any other
fronts why are you trying to grow on
Pinterest and Facebook and you're trying
to build a course and you're trying to
write an ebook you're trying to do all
this other stuff and you're barely
consistent on YouTube and your strategy
on YouTube sucks your branding on
YouTube doesn't make sense you haven't
done the heavy lifting work of planning
out your content and really getting
clear on your strategy you're spread
across multiple fronts and you don't
have very many forces and you're acting
like top tier competitors who have huge
budgets and huge staffs and you wonder
why you're losing become a strategist
the talent of a strategist is to figure
out that point of concentration and then
align all of the energy you have and
resources you have I don't have very
much time and resources and energy I get
it it's not about your resources it's
about your resourcefulness so you got to
do some guerrilla warfare you got to
take what you have it's like the fourth
Rambo movie Niche reference where like
it's a Rambo always is like one guy
versus like a bunch anybody's like he's
got little booby traps and tunnels and
he's got his thing and like a hundred
guys come after him and he figures out
how to be the one man like you can
figure it out but you got to do it with
the booby traps and with the tunnels and
with the little gas thing where you like
the thing and then everybody Burns in
the field because he got him you had gas
in the they didn't they didn't see that
coming you know you got to become a
strategist concentrate your for horses
number three pick the right battles so
99 of small YouTube channels especially
are spending their time and energy wrong
and here's two fallacies this is
interesting these are two myths that
people fall into so one myth and this
will really resonate with us is you know
business owners if you get to that level
or you have a couple team members or
you're thinking about hiring eventually
one is the better people fallacy
so what some people think is that okay
if I had more Talent if I had more if I
had like a great editor helping me if I
had all that stuff and I know that that
is the currency and language of YouTube
but here's what the the mythology
actually is the reality of the
marketplace
is that the way you actually win the
battle is through Superior strategy I'm
quoting from the book the way you win
the battle is a superior strategy not by
relying on a superior performance by
your people let me apply this to you the
solo Creator the way you're going to win
is by Superior strategy not by your
Superior performance
and that right there is sometimes an
excuse oh I'm just not talented enough
there's just the competitor I'm going
against has so much talent that's better
than me or has better looks than me
probably true and so if that is how
you're going to define whether you're
going to win or lose then you've already
chosen to lose but given this and I hope
this episode's coming together given
that you're going again I just can't go
on offense against this person because I
don't I don't have the talent enough I'm
not pretty enough is my heart wide open
this is my life too tough you ever heard
that song like if if if you're going
against them thinking that Superior
performance is the key
then someone that is better is always
going to beat you
but you've heard us say the quote from
Sally hog said different is better than
better that's why you're not going to go
against the competition you either go
around them or guerrilla warfare you go
underneath them you like dig a hole You
Dig a tunnel underneath the whole thing
and you you approach it from a whole
different deal this quote resonated with
me so much I was like dang that's so
true on YouTube the key about crushing
it in the marketplace is by having a
better strategy and what does that mean
in plain terms it's when you identify
your competitor strikes of weaknesses
you identify your strengths and
weaknesses and then you create a plan
and then you identify the market demands
the market desires okay what problems
are unsolved what are little like
fringes of the market and sometimes you
go okay maybe this approach to YouTube
isn't going to make me a YouTube
millionaire but this approach to YouTube
is going to help me build a 50k a year
channel in this small Market segment
that nobody else is paying attention to
because I'm willing to write the book on
YouTube for real estate agents and I'm
not trying to go against YouTube secrets
and I'm not trying to encourage you not
to go against YouTube Secrets hey this
is a free market I think it's a I think
the market decides I think that
capitalism Done Right is where it's a
meritocracy May the best player win but
I also believe that we're living in an
abundant World especially with how much
demand there is on YouTube and just how
many people are consuming content but
it's not the better people is not the
key or your better performance is not
the key different is better than better
what is your strengths what are your
advantages how can you use your small
YouTube channel
to create a big advantage
because most small channels are just
spending their time wrong and then the
other myth was the better product
fallacy so it was like okay the best
product always wins that's definitely
not true this is why they say content is
King but marketing is Queen and she runs
the household like product is King but
marketing is Queen and she runs the
household the best product as a win the
best marketing wins
but even more specifically here's how
they Define it the problem is that your
Market's perceived value is actually
what wins true
let's talk about fashion is that
Designer luxury brand with the Gucci
logo on it actually more valuable than
the Walmart shirt with the logo on it it
is in the mind of the prospect is the
actual Cotton itself
marginally if at all it's a that's a
branding is it the better price the
better marketing and branding that one
in that case right so is this book or
that book better of course quality of
product matters but this is why it's a
myth the problem is that marketing Wars
like military Wars are not One
automatically by the force with the
truth on its side history is always
written by the winners not the losers
what does that mean just because someone
won doesn't mean it's because they had
the best product it's probably because
they had the best marketing and that
does not mean that's not a defeatist
conclusion that you're like well shoot
my forces are not good enough right my
my energy is not good enough I can't
compete no you find the angle the
guerrilla warfare Market segment that
you could focus on and you Niche down
you get more specific and you create is
your product better
let's talk about actually creating a
product I say you created an online
course is your product better it's not
that it's even better than someone
else's that's your competitors course
it's that it's for a specific person
when you make the ideal product that
fits that person perfectly that fits
that market segment perfectly and that's
maybe a little bit too Niche all the
other competitors in the space would
never narrow down that far because
they're already established but that's
your opportunity makes sense so the myth
of a better product or the myth of
better people or your better performance
those are ultimately myths what is the
ultimate answer
Superior strategy you might debate that
and I'm happy this is a place of
conversation
um and so if you've I'm curious your
feedback I'm curious if you like
episodes like this I'm curious your
takeaway obviously you can mainly
respond on YouTube so drop me a comment
what are your insights what are your aha
moments and do you want a follow-up of
an episode like this if you are on
Spotify or apple or somewhere like that
you can rate and review the podcast in
fact specifically if you're on Spotify
it'd mean the world to me if you uh
rated the podcast and uh and then on
Apple you can leave a review and would
love your insights I know this this is a
little bit different but I've just I'm
trying to pass along the stuff that's
inspiring me and the stuff that's
impacting me if you're interested in
checking out the book marketing Warfare
or the book positioning of course we'll
have those in the show notes fascinating
reads and definitely powerful which
reinforce a lot of what we've been
learning right strategy is about picking
the right battles
with your small YouTube channel if
you're going if you're if you're
fighting battles that you were going to
lose from the start why'd you fight the
battle in the first place you know pick
the right battles position your channel
properly make the right videos stop
trying to go on offense event against
the competition and instead go around or
underneath the competition or don't even
fight the battle at all another book
along this line of thinking is the book
Blue Ocean strategy stop competing in a
red ocean we don't have time to get into
it but actually go find your blue ocean
and I want to encourage you I really do
believe confident in my very core that
Niche is the new Big and that small
channels can still dominate that small
channels can win against big competitors
that you can go from Underdog to
Champion when you go to your next level
of strategy and I want to encourage you
too if you made it this far and you
haven't seen our uh new class at
findyourtopic.com not only will it help
you I think clarify your topic and find
the most profitable topic for you so
that you can win with a small Channel
but I also believe it'll be really
helpful if you would say Sean I do want
to grow as a strategist I want to think
different I want to think bigger I've
been watching a lot of stuff maybe
you've been watching a lot of videos and
you've been maybe getting conversations
that are not at this level you've been
getting conversations that are just
about like let's get the right title on
your video which is very important let's
like you know optimize the hook also
very important but like all of that
stuff is tactics we got to get the
strategy right let's let's let's get the
right strategy pick the right battles
and then tactics are how we're going to
successfully be executing the details in
those battles 99 of other YouTube
information out there is all tactics
it's what you're getting from most other
people you're getting tactics which are
important but the underlying
foundational core strategy is the game
changer and so I hope you got value out
of this episode and head to
findyourtopic.com if you're interested
in stuff like this and want to go deeper
my name is Sean Cannell rhymes with
YouTube channel this is the think media
podcast and I'm excited to connect with
you in a future episode